Food is a favorite pastime for many
which is convenient because we needed to
live but what would happen to you in
your body if you were to completely stop
eating food right now in the first six
hours all is fairly normal your body
begins to break down glycogen which
stores energy in your body into glucose
which are cells use as fuel around 25%
of energy generated this way is used for
your brain alone while the rest goes
some muscle tissue and red blood cells
but after about six hours this method of
energy production halts as the glycogen
stores deplete which can lead to the
notorious Hangry or hungry and angry
feeling that many of us know too well at
this point your body at his estate
called ketosis as it begins to fast or
starve because there's very little
glucose in your blood your body must
begin to break down fat for energy this
fat is in turn broken down into fatty
acids however your brain can't use long
chain fatty acids which is a problem
because there's no more glucose and the
faster too large to cross the blood
brain barrier your brain changes modes
and begins to use ketone bodies for
energy which are short-changing
relatives of fatty acids this works for
the time being but ultimately only 75%
of the brain's energy requirements can
come from ketones it still needs glucose
which means your cognitive functioning
becomes impaired now it's important to
mention that you don't have to be
starving to be in ketosis many people
enter this phase if they're on a low
carb diet or professional athletes who
use all their carbs for an extended
period of time like marathon runners
will be in this state as well however
beyond 72 hours not only will your mood
and energy suffer but your brain will
start to break down your body's own
protein the proteins release amino acids
which can be converted into glucose
which is great news for your brain but
bad news for your body basically your
body is cannibalizing itself by
destroying your muscle mass
in women under nutrition often shut down
the menstrual cycle as the body tries to
reduce energy expenditure bone density
diminishes and both men and women may
experience loss of libido within a few
weeks the body's immune system will be
so we can without any vitamins or
minerals that many will die from disease
otherwise it will continue to use up all
energy sources in till there was no
glucose fat tissue or muscle man left
one of the more common causes of death
is cardiac arrhythmia or heart attack
due to the tissue degradation in the
heart diaphragm and body this is fairly
common in those suffering from anorexia
of course the body experiences severe
organ failure all around
starvation can lead to death in a short
as three weeks or up to seventy days as
documented during the Irish hunger
strikes in 1981 though the duration of
survival is greatly influenced by how
hydrated you are and the amount of fat
reserves your body has which some ways
is incredible that the body can sustain
for so long with no food and get
approximately seven hundred and ninety
five million people around the world
have to deal with this reality the good
news is that the seven richest countries
have pledged to lift 500 million people
out of hunger and malnutrition by 2030
but we need to hold them accountable
we're working with an organization
called global citizen to do just that
and here's a really easy way that you
can help out to buy sharing this video
and then heading to the global citizen
website forum here you'll be adding her
voice to an important educational
movement towards ending hunger worldwide
you can click the screen or use the
links in the description it really only
takes a few moments
and subscribe to our weekly science
videos